[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the introductory chapter to
the entire harry potter story the
philosopher's stone now let me just
start off by saying that the
philosopher's stone isn't everyone's
favorite some felt that it was too
juvenile too innocent but i for one am a
huge fan of the first film and the
immense nostalgia that it brings the
philosopher's stone was the preliminary
introduction and gateway to the
wizarding world on the big screen and
for that it will forever remain in my
heart but no film production goes
without its fair share of mistakes prop
failures misread lines bloopers these
are all elements of a production they're
an inevitability however what i want to
discuss today are those elements of
filmmaking that slipped through the
cracks the one that made it to the final
cut i'm of course talking about movie
mistakes harry potter and the
philosopher's stone though a masterpiece
is certainly not without its fair share
of mistakes and today i wanted to share
20 of them with you all these mistakes
come in many forms simple oversights
visible equipment crew and continuity
errors if you like the style of video i
can do it for all of the films just
leave a comment letting me know down
below let's get started kicking things
off we're brought to the quidditch pitch
where harry is hanging on to his jinxed
nimbus 2000 for dear life this scene
occurs just after hermione sets snape's
cloak on fire and here if we look
closely we can actually see the wire
rods taped to the broomstick leading to
underneath both of harry's sleeves
next up we have another mistake in the
same quidditch scene where harry is
upright and trying his best to stay on
his unruly broomstick
just before panning to this still we see
hermione say toron leave it to me
with the close-up on harry we can
actually see a seat underneath his
broomstick which made it more
comfortable for the actors to sit on
next up we're brought to one of the
opening sequences at the zoo
at the zoo dudley is being unruly and
harassing the snake also pushing harry
aside this leads to a disgruntled harry
removing the glass between dudley and
the snake in this first still we can see
here the snake actually disappears
however once dudley has actually fallen
in we can see the snake reappear in the
frame
next up we're brought to the girls
lavatory during the fated troll attack
here we have young hermione trying to
get away from the troll backing towards
the cubicle doors
the issue here the cubicle door seems to
go all the way to the ground however in
the next scene hermione can be seen
scrambling underneath the cubicles which
shouldn't be possible here we have a
scene where the trio have made it past
fluffy the devil's snare and in this
moment the keys married those hermione
key which she then catches and runs over
to the door with it's at this point that
we can see electrical cable hanging in
plain sight in the background that
wasn't visible in previous shots
this is an interesting one when quirrell
enters the great hall and tells everyone
that there's a troll in the dungeon
dumbledore proceeds to shout silence
followed by teachers will follow me to
the dungeons at this point it pans to a
shot of mcgonagall and some candles that
are very clearly hanging via visible
wires
at the start of term feast just after
being sorted into gryffindor harry sits
down on one side of the table however
very shortly after the feast appears on
the table and at this point harry is
sitting opposite ron next to percy and
hermione in this scene petunia is
bringing dudley over to his vast pile of
presents and perhaps one of the most
blatant equipment related blenders in
the film a black microphone wire can be
seen in plain sight around petunia's
neck not to be confused with her apron
strings in this scene the trio are just
vacating the room where they first
encountered fluffy after running away
they decide to head back to the
gryffindor tower and it's at this point
that we can see a crew member's feet
underneath the door behind them this is
another weird one that could be up for
debate here we can see hermione's hair
in madame hooch's class with some sort
of crimp in it however in the following
scene and in all subsequent scenes
hermione's hair appears to be completely
straight
just after being knocked off of the
knight's horse in the chest challenge
which is protecting the stone ron
weasley can be seen falling to the
ground
it's in this moment that if you look
closely you can see black protective
gear underneath his clothing in this
scene which occurs just after dumbledore
and harry have a discussion about the
mirror of erised harry is walking in the
snow outside with hedwig on his arm when
the shot zooms in to harry with hedwig
we can see a jazz around hedwig's leg
that is a strap tethering hedwig to
harry's sleeve however in the very next
shot this jess is no longer there in
this scene which occurs just after the
trio escaped fluffy and the devil's
snare the trio are faced with a room
full of keys and a floating broomstick
when ron and hermione walk away to the
door on the other side of the room we
can see harry standing next to the broom
and if we look very closely we can see a
bar clearly supporting the floating
object back to the troll scene here we
can see an overhead shot of harry
clinging on for dear life as he grabs
the trolls club the scene looks fine at
first glance but if we look closely we
can actually see some of the crew's
equipment in the bottom left corner back
to fluffy in this scene the trio have
just entered fluffy's quarters but the
giant three-headed dog is asleep
however the trio suddenly come to the
realization that fluffy has woken up and
a giant glob of slobber lands on ron
what's interesting here however is that
in the very next scene only moments
later ron is lying in the devil's snare
with a completely dry shirt
in this scene hagrid has just brought
harry with him to gringotts to visit
harry's vault and conduct some of
dumbledore's business the issue here is
the envelope the envelope we see here is
creased with the bow tied a particular
way however in the very next moment as
hagrid passes the letter over the
envelope is suddenly completely fine
with no creases and the bow position
appears to have shifted this is a good
one back at the zoo just after dudley
falls into the snake pit we can see what
looks to be a stick prodding the snake
into action in the very next moment the
stick is gone in fact we can actually
see it begin to leave the frame this
stick actually belonged to one of the
crew members who is poking the snake in
order to make it move
in this scene back at the quidditch
pitch there are actually quite a few
mistakes going on throughout the main
ones however are these wires that are
attached to these brooms the wires in
question are attached to the broom
handle between their legs and extend
down to a clamped loop around their feet
in this scene which occurs just after
harry has retrieved the philosopher's
stone we see harry crash and fall to the
stairs after voldemort's soul flies
through him what should be noted here
however is a that he's unconscious and b
the way that he lands moments later in a
follow-up scene harry's on position is
completely different and moved way too
much for someone that was unconscious i
enjoy this one quite a lot as it's a
favorite scene of mine one of many here
we can see harry carefully taking notes
in snape's class with careful neat and
most importantly small handwriting
however in the following shot we get a
glance of harry's notebook from afar and
the writing looks nothing like what
harry had written down in the previous
frame and there you have it 20 mistakes
in the first installment of harry potter
you want me to do more of these for the
other films if so like the video
subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment down below thanks for watching
until next time your wizard howery
[Music]
you